so there's a few angles to this next
story that I want to talk about
yesterday the stock market had a good
day and when the stock market has a good
day
lots of companies have a good day but I
noticed that healthcare stocks had a
particularly good day yesterday on the
left side of your screen you see that
United Healthcare was up 11% anthem
health was up 15%
Cigna was up 10% and meanwhile some
defense contractors did well but not
quite as well Lockheed Martin Northrop
Grumman Raytheon were up 4 to 5%
this was a clear reaction to the Super
Tuesday winds of Joe Biden now why do I
say that well first of all Joe Biden's
big health care plan is a public option
this is not hugely threatening to these
health care corporations when Joe Biden
wins Super Tuesday and at least appears
to be on the fast track to the
nomination that's a signal of new
information to the market that if Trump
gets reelected or if Biden gets elected
the gravy train for the health insurance
companies is more or less going to
remain unchanged compared to if Bernie
was president and started a bonafide
push for Medicare for all that really
could threaten the profits of these
health care companies that tells us a
lot now a lot of people wrote to me and
said you know David it's a bit of a
cheap shot because it was a big stock
market day yesterday everything was up
well hold on a second though the major
indices were up about three to four
percent defense contractors were up
about the same amount four to five
percent but healthcare stocks were up
two to three times that amount so it's
not enough to say well everything was up
so there's nothing to see here
and even more over unrelated companies
like Tesla for example my beloved Tesla
shares weren't basically up at all Tesla
was basically even so to write this off
as nothing to see because it was a good
day for the market as if all of a sudden
the market is not reacting to actual new
information that is relevant it's
materially relevant who is the
Democratic nominee to the future profits
of healthcare companies it would be very
naive to pretend that that's not what's
going on but then there's the next angle
Joe Biden has not made it a secret that
if he's president the main crossroads of
our are going to remain fundamentally
unchanged he actually was caught saying
this to donors and remember when Joe
Biden said I need you very badly to
wealthy donors no one standard of living
will change nothing would fundamentally
change rich people are just as patriotic
as poor people we may not want to
demonize anyone who has made money and I
hope if I win this nomination I won't
let you down that also applies to the
centers of industries so of course
markets like the Biden wins it's a
continuing gravy train for healthcare
stocks it's very good for them it's not
so good for people who need care and
can't afford it but that's why health
care stocks were up ten to fifteen
percent yesterday and then on top of
that there's always a layer with the
markets of predictability and
maintaining the status quo markets like
that Joe Biden said it he then won a
bunch of primaries you really don't have
to dig too deeply to figure out what's
going on here combined more generally
with this erratic nature of the market
under Trump up down up down
particularly with the cool party virus
as we are calling it you'll understand
why if you watched yesterday's show the
market is up and down drastically
already the highs are high the lows are
low
yesterday was a high and it was a
particularly good day for healthcare
stocks that are experiencing what we
could call some relief as a result of
the Super Tuesday results the question
is is what's good for healthcare stocks
good for the average American I think we
all know the answer to that